>> LET'S NOT FORGET THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI WAS ACTUALLY
FIRED FOR MISCONDUCT.
THE PRESIDENT IS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE MATTER.
AND WE WILL GO FROM THERE.
>> Bret: SO TREY GOWDY HAS
BEEN BREACHED IN THE CLASSIFIED
BRIEFING AND HE SAID HE DOESN'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH WHAT THE FBI
DATED AS FAR AS AN INFORMANT IN
AND AROUND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HERE WAS THE PRESIDENT LAST
NIGHT.
>> President Trump: HOW DO YOU
LIKE THE FACT THAT THEY HAD
PEOPLE INFILTRATING OUR
CAMPAIGN?
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
>> IT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP
HIMSELF WHO SAID NUMBER ONE I
DIDN'T COLLUDE WITH RUSSIA BUT
IF ANYONE CONNECTED WITH THAT
THE CAMPAIGN DATA, I WOULD LIKE
TO FIND THAT OUT.
>> WHAT WORRIES ME IS BEYOND THE
RUSSIANS THEMSELVES, OR THEY ARE
MAKING ATTACKS AGAINST THE WHOLE
OF THE FBI.
AND, A.B. STODDARD IS THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR.
THAT'S ALSO ON THE RADIO, AND
OUR GUEST IS HOLDING DOWN THE
FORT.
I THINK WE NEED TO PAY VERY
CLOSE ATTENTION TO WHAT TROY
GAUDI IS SAYING BECAUSE HE HAS
EXTRAORDINARY ACCESS TO ACTUAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS.
WE ALL CHATTER ABOUT IT AND
SPECULATE ALL DAY AND ALL NIGHT,
BUT HE KNOWS MORE THAN 99.9% OF
US DO BECAUSE HE HAS SEEN AN
ACTUAL.
SO WHEN THIS WAS AN
APPROPRIATELY PREDICATED
INVESTIGATION AND THE INFORMANT
WITHIN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS
NOT A SPY, OR ACTING
INAPPROPRIATELY IN ANY WAY, AND,
WE ARE IN THAT ELEMENT OF OUR
INTERVIEW, BUT THE QUOTE ALSO TO
ME THAT STICKS OUT, HE SAID "IT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF."
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT.
WHAT HE WAS EXAMINING IS NOT
TARGETING THE PRESIDENT AND THAT
MATTERS.
>> AS YOU LOOK AT THE COVERAGE
AROUND THE HORN, THE SECOND PART
REALLY GOT CHOPPED OFF.
>> THE FIRST PART GOT IGNORED,
THE SECOND PART -- I THINK THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF REASONS TO
EXPLAIN THIS.
ONE, TREY GOWDY HAS MORE TRUST
IN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THEN
DEVIN NUNES DOES.
I THINK THAT'S PRETTY CLEAR
HERE.
>> WE SHOULD POINT OUT THAT WE
HAVE NOT TALKED ABOUT NUNEZ.
BUT I THINK THE IMPORTANT THING
IS, THE HOUSE WAS TRYING TO GET
DOCUMENTS, AND WE ARE TRYING TO
SEE FOR EXAMPLE, DID THE
INFORMANT ISSUE GIVE REPORTS TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT?
IF THE INFORMANT TALKED TO
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS, DID HE
WRITE IT UP?
THE FACT IS, THEY HAVEN'T SEEN
THAT STUFF YET.
SO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CAN
SAY, WE ARE FOLLOWING ALL THE
ROLLS.
BUT THE HOUSE HASN'T SEEN THE
STUFF YET.
>> Bret: THE OTHER QUESTION
IS, IF THE PRESIDENT-ELECT IS
GETTING CLASSIFIED BRIEFING IS
AS PRESIDENT-ELECT, WHY IS HE
NOT IN THE LOOP IF IT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHY WAS HE NOT TOLD WHAT THE
INFORMANT IS TRYING TO DO ABOUT
FINDING ANY RUSSIA CONNECTION.
>> ONE WOULD THINK HE HAD THEM
ALONG THE WAY.
HE WAS TOLD THIS WAS HAPPENING,
AND PEOPLE ARE QUESTIONING AND
THEY ARE IMPUTING HIS INTEGRITY
AND HIS MOTIVE TODAY.
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT AND
BECAUSE IN THE FEVER SWAMPS, AND
IN TRAVEL BATTLE, PEOPLE WANT TO
PAINT THIS LIKE HE IS A SECRET
LORETTA
LYNCH-HILLARY CLINTON-OBAMA
PARTISAN, FIGHTING TO COVER UP A
CORRUPT FBI.
HE'S DOING THIS BECAUSE HE KNOWS
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING IS
WHAT SENATOR WARNER DESCRIBES.
HE'S LAUNCHING AN ASSAULT ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IS THAT
WE DEPEND ON IN THIS
AND IT'S WORKING.
IF THIS IS A CAMPAIGN TO
DISCREDIT BOB MUELLER'S FINDINGS
AND NOTHING ELSE, TRUMP KNOWS
THERE WAS NO SPY INFILTRATING
HIS CAMPAIGN.
AND THEY WERE CHECKING HE'S
DOING IT ANYWAY.
HERE'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT THEY
SET ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION
OVERALL.
>> PEOPLE KIND OF GOT EXHAUSTION
FROM THE DAY TODAY, BACK AND
FORTH OF THIS STORY.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC WILL
BE TIRED OF IT, IF THIS IS NOT
WOUND DOWN IN THIS CALENDAR
YEAR.
>> I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE THAT IS
LOOKING INTO THIS WHO WAS REALLY
AGGRESSIVE IN THE BEGINNING.
AND, SEEMS TO BE SAYING, WE NEED
TO WRAP THIS THING UP.
>> BASICALLY ECHOING THE
VICE PRESIDENT FROM A FEW WEEKS
AGO URGING ROBERT MUELLER TO GET
THIS THING FINISHED UP SOON.
I THINK IT MAKES SENSE ON SOME
LEVEL, INVESTIGATIONS DON'T NEED
TO BE UNENDING AND FOREVER WHICH
SEEMS TO BE THE STANDARD THAT
SOME CRITICS WANT IN THIS CASE,
WHICH IS THE CLOUD THAT
CONTINUES TO HANG OVER HIM.
THAT WILL PREVENT OTHER HOSTILE
POWERS FROM -- IT WOULD BE NICE
TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE THE
NEXT ELECTION.
SO WHAT WARNER SAID THERE, I
THINK YOU ARE RIGHT, IT IS
SIGNIFICANT.
A DEMOCRAT SAYING, OKAY, LET'S
GO.
>> Bret: "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
AND WHY DON'T YOU GET BACK ON IN
AND WHY DON'T YOU GET BACK ON IT
AND WHY DON'T YOU GET BACK ON IE
GAME.
THE SESSION WAS NEVER AGAINST --
RECUSE HIMSELF, AND IF HE WAS
GOING TO RECUSE HIMSELF, HE
SHOULD HAVE TOLD ME BEFORE THE
JOB AND I WOULD HAVE PICKED
SOMEONE ELSE.
>> WEEK THEY TOLD ME LATER, ALL
BY THE WAY, I'M NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE.
IN THE MOST IMPORTANT CASE IN
THE OFFICE, I'D BE FRUSTRATED,
TOO.
>> I THINK THE SOUND YOU PLAYED
FROM THE PRESIDENT IS FROM JULY
OF LAST YEAR.
HE STILL MAD ABOUT IT AND HE'S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE MAD ABOUT IT,
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES THAT THAT
THE GROUNDS THAT SESSIONS USED
TO RECUSE HIMSELF WERE KNOWABLE
BEFORE SESSIONS WERE      WAS EE
BEFORE SESSIONS WERE      WAS EN
APPOINTED ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SESSIONS COULD HAVE SAID, I WANT
TO RECUSE MYSELF FROM THIS VERY
IMPORTANT CASE.
THE PRESIDENT IS CLEARLY STILL
MAD ABOUT IT, AND FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WHICH
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONVERTING A SUCCESSOR AS